hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
what's your name
I'm Julia Tran folia Julian shuffle is
here with us today go falling around
social media have you ever heard of this
channel called corridor true no I must
introduce you to a channel that I know
you will get hooked on this segment is
called VFX artists react to bad and
great CGI these guys are great I've met
them in person you're gonna love these
guys trust me you'll love it oh I can't
wait yeah I don't know how to tell you
this I know Julia because I was in a
short film that you guys should go check
out it's on YouTube right now Civil
Defence Red Rover it turned out
wonderful and Julia is the director of
it it's an alt history war short film
everyone in LA is always like I'm doing
something and I sometimes agree to be a
part of them I don't plug everyone that
I've ever bitten but this one I will
plug because it turned out pretty damn
good so go check it out today I
guarantee when you you see that this 22
year old 2 foot 5 inch curling this
heavy-water short vowel head go check it
out civil defense at Red Rover put a lot
of hard work into it and there's some
really good use of VFX ok more god bless
him my producer my VFX guy my colorist
gorgeous work there were moments where I
was like when did they shoot
oh wait that's edited yeah most of it is
practical where there are moments where
I was like oh wait that's VFX cuz I was
like when did they shoot that anyhow are
you ready
Julia Chun I got a high that out ha ha
ha my last name is a lot easier than
your Italian last
[Laughter]
[Music]
so cool every shot has a real element to
it this is the actual yeah it's just a
preview what's the I love their voices
sponsoring today's episode we've worked
with them to learn how a month's free
welcome back to another wonderful
episode of VFX artists react what do we
talk about today Niko they're gonna talk
about some really good I haven't seen it
yet never seen Supergirl that's how I
audition for Julia short Power Rangers
[Music]
that one of her abilities I can build
houses
[Music]
this definitely looks like a mature
after effects effects whether they're
biting off more than they can chew
a full CG head with the Hogs the lips
you're biting off a lot there by the way
I think they use the same shot twice
here go back a little further before the
woman just randomly transforms so that
reaction she punches them hard enough
time to fly 20 feet over to a wall yeah
what does she fly back coordinator glows
yeah like there's no blue on the actors
like there's no like blue light really
being casting them particles there the
thing that I would want to add though
you can even drop in like a literally a
fire embers element and just color it
blue and just have a look
yeah they look better I'm all for
acknowledging you know short time crappy
decisions on the producer stuff like
that
I can't excuse bad multiply Shias it
sounds like the m4 muzzle flash from the
front where the gas expands out the side
of the muzzle brake it's like really
tiny it looks it looks ridiculous
she's really just jumping on till you
crash bad in front of a green screen and
you're just taking her in her out to the
left you can see her hair go straight up
yeah so it's like yeah I just not had
her accelerate I would just let her
continue diving cut in the next shot
she's spinning around now dancing don't
worry
yeah wise on screen every single for the
VFX shot is locked off they're going
with like the easiest way you can
approach these shots and making them
look really bad nothing covering up your
weaknesses like this shot of her close
up like that
that's yeah this might have been the
case or it's like I heard that the
effects shots need to be locked off when
you shoot them if it's not locked off
it's gonna be way more expensive it'd
take a lot more time it's probably what
they're thinking I think you're totally
right I know people who work on shows
like this and it's usually just like
literally the tiniest team
it was probably legitimately one person
who probably worked on this whole thing
in probably two or three days
terrible the effects tariffs right I
haven't seen it since I watch on VHS
during my birthday let me see G and
Titanic is the water and the occasional
extra people on sale really there's
already crazy things happen so for
example that shadow the iceberg passing
by the boat no motives there none the
ice that lands on the boat comes from
the iceberg it's all for it off the side
there everything's real there except for
the iceberg in the sky is that iceberg
is actually a miniature that's been
filmed separately
it looks flawless Lani been with a
ladder miniatures huh I love that they
didn't Doris take note manzanera
or the only CG the only fully rendered
images you can do is a Mason extras long
alright so they're real and they're
touching is real the ship extending into
the background I imagine it was probably
an actual like films miniature is nature
and they're filming the scene with a
motion control camera yeah they're doing
the shot again with the emotions scaled
down for the miniature and this stuff is
all over the place they would actually
film the shot in real life or the person
on set the motion controlled rig even
scaled down that emotion in film that
same motion again on the miniature and
just if the two on top of each other so
the app really sparked the after
compositing is really easy
yeah it's a green screen key set you're
cleared to top the other one and all the
other work is done from you holy crap
this was like 2,000 right and it's 1997
he said it two minutes ago one side
don't worry about it what yeah what yeah
200 million dollars which is the biggest
budget back in the day yeah so there's
an interesting problem and insolvent
Titanic with all your miniature is going
into the water you get to start reading
the scale of the water know how they
water droplets are yeah they actually
needed really really really big
miniatures to actually sink into the
water and have it look correct extend as
miniature as biggest one six Wow I think
they go down to like one thirtieth I'm
not mistaken so this is a shot where
he's on a green screen we are looking at
a miniature because we can see the turn
of the ship cuz we can see the pressure
ship and also all the water work and the
reason it looks so real is because in
Israel it's just a miniature that boy
right there
that's a full-size set they're sinking
into the tank this isn't why I'm
watching this man this kind of movie
wouldn't get made anymore know that
they're doing so much of this stuff
practically no no crazy model shot right
here this is all model the whole thing I
think you do this twice a day once they
rebuilt it over two weeks and then did
it again Wow all those people think all
the base that we take for granted that's
like for free to grab on line today
didn't exist back then and they had to
go they had to capture all of it and
they stick all those little 3d people
all over the back of the ship the visual
effects in Titanic are really not that
complicated the magic in Titanic it's
them going out and getting the hundreds
of people in the water in full costume
and getting the full modeler ship and
sinking it in the water tank look that's
the hard stuff and that's the stuff
these days that they don't do anymore
because all that hard stuff is now done
with CG that's that's that's tough man
because this definitely has a sense of
realism yeah that you don't get with CG
this one's for James Cameron
oh this money looks familiar
Gaetano it's for all see this video I
can die peacefully now the more vicious
version of the previous boss dynamics
video we put out back in June hi we
wanted everything to be as real as
possible so what you got on the quarter
channel if you haven't already we have
lots of cool shorts like this one
usually visual effects days hence why
we're here - initial text artists react
there's also excited by side comparison
of the before and after of this looks so
real look like the robot and
interstellar not really practical I mean
not in this case but it looks at so I
was really surprised to find out at this
scene the whole scene is all CG 100%
whoa
[Music]
Wow I was awesome the feeders what
Quintin Beck is a serial in the comics
he is a VFX artist what yeah has let
gonna wash to that he actually is
wearing a real Island like motion
capturing so spider-man parvum home is
one of our most requested reactions and
ideas video movies TV shows etc
electrocytes react to losing the comment
below it it's great inspiration for us
so if you are the VFX artist who worked
on the shot this sequence would be your
VFX real right yeah I mean this was
probably the coolest moment of the
entire movie it was a company called
frame store so in order to break down
the sequence there's actually not a lot
to break down it's just it's all CG and
yeah there's different you know some
different techniques going in but this
is where I would like to extra take a
moment and delve into what makes this CG
look real how do you take a sphere
sitting on a plane how you bring it up
to this level where it looks like a
sphere that can be sitting in this world
well the first time you got a dinner set
up your light frame by frame
NHGRI is the 360 degree photo of a real
environment so you're getting real light
Sanders the HDR provides both the color
of the lighting in the direction of that
lighting and the intensity of that
lighting from every possible direction
the next thing you want to do this fear
is you want to give the surface in color
the first thing after you actually
identify the colors you actually have to
give a physical texture how do the
grooves reflect light in different
directions so for that we'll use what's
called like a bump map or a normal map
and that will actually tell the render
engine that's sort of terrain that sort
of object will have like a wooden sphere
will have like little grooves between
each of the wooden slats and that's like
the micro detail that would be way too
hard to go in and do my hand so from
there I determine what is reflective and
what absorbs light completely just like
all these other match that we're listing
off this would be a black-and-white map
whatever black is a hundred percent
reflective whatever is white is not
reflective at all and there's a lot of
gray in between there clearly every
surface around you is reflective even
the ones that seem rough the only
difference between that and a mirror for
example is the Damier is taking the
light rays and bouncing off at sharp
angles whereas a rough surface takes
library and scat
a bunch of different directions your
color track keep it up yeah it brings me
back to physics how glossy something is
and normal map /bo map so you can
display some maps to give a surface it's
micro textures and rendering all of that
and they physically based rendering
system using ray tracing and good
simulation of light rays just from a
pure rendering perspective that's how
you make something look real and that's
like the foundation of what's going on
in these scenes for spider-man the
systems that you do all that and just
one go and Harrison work are only a few
years old and that's why you're kind of
seeing these movies just starting to hit
these little real legends that they're
getting - I think 2019 marks the year or
CG let's cross the line into photo
realism and we cannot tell difference
yeah absolutely
it's Gary how long that must have been
to render we're looking the wrong way
cuz Sam's working on something right now
we're doing Star Wars rated-r
specifically I'd go to sleep every night
wondering the same age-old question who
the heck frame they're in the movie
answers movie not to incorporate
cartoons in a live-action it was the
first movie to do it with camera motion
the camera is all on place panning
around doing crazy moves and interacting
with people all over the place the 2d
and 3d is really funny they don't do
that anymore no no but it totally has a
different feeling to proteins are
holding real things real piano is
sharing and the first time ever Donald
and Daffy on screen at the same time in
order to blend these worlds it was the
first time since on character surprising
real objects
GOx how did they film those like real
serving platters but with cartoons ern
I'm gonna answer my question well tell
me the answer and you go you know the
answer is it like a thick frame they're
moving it around with Clint's pretty
clothes
this whole set is built and raised off
the floor and underneath it
our people have sticks with the serving
trays on them walking along in this wow
they do all that that's true okay and
they're not painting out the sticks
they're just covering up the sticks with
the cartoons Wow they had to build all
that so you could ever see them a stick
right oh he's sitting on something
that's doing what wasn't even attached
to anything he's actually like yeah they
like rigged up and it's actually a stunt
driver seeing the back of it okay Wow I
have taken the effects on Roger Rabbit
for granted
best effects you will take for granted
it's got to be believable so you're not
supposed to notice this was a question
neither the chair move just move the
chair the real gun by the way the
cartoon is holding hard to me been
freaky just like a gun ghost good the
water spraying out of Roger rabbit's
mouth so that's a little tube coming up
that he's pretending to push down to his
level hose on it wash the handcuffs on
Bob Hoskins wrists
they're stiff Chucky Bob Hoskins is
doing a public hearing himself his
wrists
really mm-hmm that's awesome
that's so hot in here this is a computer
compositing where you're just taking the
layers and adding them in your computer
you're literally taking the background
film and the hand-drawn film and taking
both those and shining light through
that onto another piece of film yeah
holy cow that's like paint film frames
yeah so actually for Sleeping Beauty
tell me all about Sleeping Beauty once
this video is done Julie I am the
director now we have to listen to their
app you're right we're at digital
therefore what does expressvpn you might
ask well this is BPM it's the privacy it
basically encrypts and helps keep your
data safe by projecting it out into a
big network of cool proxy servers make
it hard for hackers and FBI agents to
monitor your internet traffic we've all
been there there's something you want to
know about it but you don't want to
google it because you're worried that
you know being a certain tree well
actually since we worked with these guys
VPN we've been using it is good yeah
we're just safe
john has set us up and if you want a
cool little discount or cool code and
her this one cor are idor see our aw and
you can go do the X PR es SVP and
dot-com look at his expressvpn coms
ice-cold our crew it's less than seven
dollars a month with a 30 day back I
love that idea
[Laughter]
sweet I got I got that short film
they're talking about what were you
saying about Sleeping Beauty yeah not
relevant at all you just had to tell you
you had to get out so my VHS tape of
Sleeping Beauty growing up at the very
end of the credits Disney would come out
and he'd explain how they made the movie
and how they didn't go bankrupt making
it million dollars back in 1958 I think
I'm very bad at years they actually
hired Gothic artists to do the
background so they're real paintings and
they would actually paint each of the
wider newly developed frames so you are
looking at a painting when you watch
that film it is not true art that does
put those it does like it's kind of like
what did you think a quarter cruise
video oh I love them they're so
knowledgeable I feel like I'm learning
about VFX and the ways to properly do
them not only in camera but then in post
and I think the biggest bit is knowing
where you have to go and post so that
you can film it correctly one thing
that's cool about these guys is you know
them being VFX artists they do emphasize
that it's best to do as much in camera
and practical as possible and only use
VFX when you really need to use VFX cuz
that's when VFX actually does really
shine when they're talking about Titanic
I didn't know any of this making of of
Titanic I never learned all that like oh
wow they did that all with miniatures or
even that moment where Jack DiCaprio is
that the do you know boats I don't know
the name of the edge of the boat yeah
what what would you call them yeah we'll
go with that because it the railing that
that was all green screen they put
DiCaprio and his buddy in a different
moment surrounded by green screen and
then they just planted him there I did
not realize that's how it was done
beyond that even with the iceberg stuff
of how what they did was they they made
a miniature iceberg all that I had no
idea the amount of extras different
splicing they had to do but they did as
much as they could in camera and
practical and nowadays they would just
CGI it and I think that's why Titanic
holds up
pretty well is because that big
climactic moment for the powerful
dramatic heft for the ship crack at half
it and go down you need that to look and
feel as real as possible and literally
like 20 years later looking at this
footage damn that still looks really
really good and nowadays it would just
be CGI unfortunately I mean there's a
huge difference even when you're like on
set and filming when the actors can be
in that environment and see the ice
pouring at them imagine okay this giant
monolith iceberg is coming at us
it totally informs the performances and
the blocking and the camera and
everybody's much more inspired and
understands what they're about to see
I've been sory and Miquelon was talking
about how when they did the x-men movies
they were in like this giant room of
green and as a theater actor that's the
worst because there's no environment to
play with there's no energy as they say
yeah VFX is one of those things where it
elevates something but when everything
is VFX then you're just in in a computer
and that can be really limiting what
they're talking about though too with
how 2019 has become the year of
photorealism we have the Lion King which
was all about
look how frickin entirely animated movie
yeah they're calling live action no it's
totally animated entire time I've
watched the video of the VFX artists of
Avengers endgame there were so many
things in there that I didn't realize
like whoa that is all CGI I thought at
least this building that they're in is
real but apparently like no well what's
every frame of that movie is pretty much
CGI even like certain costumes they were
wearing that I I was blown away by how
that is CGI and when they're talking
about what spider-man far from home that
whole sequence which is my favorite
secrets in the whole movie I noticed
very early on like even with the Tobey
Maguire days of spider-man 1 versus
spider-man 2 nowadays it I noticed that
the lighting for CGI heavy stuff they
often make it really dark to make it
look more real mmm like I watch Gemini
man and it looks so great the young Will
Smith when it's in really dark lighting
we can't see Princess Leia it wasn't
like brightly yeah road 1 and it's like
I mean it looks right but the uncanny
a little weird yeah so we are Matt we
are getting better though at master I
haven't seen the Irishman yet but I hear
that looks great I hear like you quickly
look past the de-aging the Essex of Dee
aging is super debatable right now I
think you we should do it yeah full on
dee age have you seen the Godfather -
I've seen if the Godfather 2 came out
today and Marlon Brando was still alive
we would have been like
sorry De Niro you can't be young Vito
Corleone we're just gonna die aged
Marlon Brando instead and it would have
been better
oh ha - I don't mean he like wouldn't
refuse to learn his lines because he's
like I need to react right yes so he'd
have his fellow actors wear his lines so
you can look at them and read them
Brando is the best actor we should have
done that on this setup I know now would
that would helps a lot wouldn't it but
hey those one-take wonders man you were
insane can I just say how incredibly
shamelessly go back to plug in our work
well I just want to plug Gregg because
you're him as an actor as a dramatic
actor and it's truly impressive
I mean you pulled out a beautiful
performance and I'm very grateful for
all your hard work I appreciate you
saying all that especially the dramatic
actor stuff but sounds like a new man
yes I don't want to plug Gregg oh yeah
that's all I've been stuck on I mean PG
making things awkward around here the
whole thing with spider-man 1 & 2 the
VFX I noticed greatly improved from
spider-man 1 just minor went to you with
Tobey Maguire because of how you do
lighting it seemed like a lot that went
into even though it was all computer
lighting with far from home the
attention to detail of cropping with
your lighting and the shading is just as
important and valuable in order to make
your VFX look that much more realistic
still you know do it as much
cameras possible the one that blew me
away was Roger Rabbit I know crazy pig
movies guess that they had done all
those practical effects and it's so
funny because the gags even like the guy
getting sprayed in the face at the water
yeah it reads so well I actually have
not seen Roger Rabbit until a few months
ago it was very recent my girlfriend
showed it to me and I was like I've
never finished this movie I don't I
don't know for some reason never
question how complicated of a shoot that
must have been that is more complicated
than what we do now it's so seamless and
it seems so simple it's like what you
were talking about like you're not
supposed to question it and it did seem
like oh this is probably easy to do
they're just animated them I'm there and
I'm gonna find out in order to do all
these things that I would have never
thought about if something as little as
carrying this is what I told them when I
met them in person is the thing that
their channel has helped me out the most
with is realizing how much I take for
granted
well the penguin carrying the the tray
that's something I would have never
bothered to be like I just watch the
movie and go oh cool that was a cool
shot and they set it up like a theater -
you know how there's a stage and then
they're below puppeteering and I can't
okay it's hard enough balancing a tray
with a drink on it - then throw it on a
stick and be under agent Lee going
through all the people they had to build
a whole set just for that I think
nowadays you would probably just get
some little person and some green screen
suit and just hold the stick right but
no they had to go all out here Roger
Rabbit kudos to them for the amount of
hard work they put in there and the
actors to Bob Hoskins having to do that
performance part will make that movie so
work so well even to this day is I
really believe Bob Hoskins is
interacting with these people these
these animated characters and come to
find out the reason hey dude it's all on
his own you know
Charlie Chaplin though it's like that
classic comedy true he was the master of
in-camera effects that whole scene where
he's like riding around on his little
bike and he's supposed to be on the on
the edge of a building you can see the
whole city scape below what they did was
they just really had like a little
miniature picture of a cityscape really
a video of the cityscape and closer to
the camera so it appeared bigger than it
was and then he's out here on the
background cycling around so that edge
appears on the camera as if it's right
here and he will fall but really it's
just the floor you're so smart
I just spent a lot of time on the
Internet these guys I can't imagine how
they they're able to work in these
programs they are beefy programs and
they take a lot of time to learn all
right guys well thank you so much for
being here Julia thanks for being here
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell
more importantly watch the short film it
took a lot of hard work took me three
days her please go check it out as soon
as you can I like this with a patient a
shot to a man named Andrew Nickerson
Andrew my friend we haven't talked in a
while today I tend to talk with our
patrons and sometimes private messages
and then they get mad at me when I don't
get back to them at a timely matter but
I give tonight handsome and I stolen
long long conversations Andrew lives
closer to were you from oh he's from
Washington no you're from Boston that's
not I mean same coast I'll give you that
that's the same time I was trying to
make this work Andrew right now is
single with a great career Julia are you
single I mean yes can I set you up on a
date with Andrew Nickerson please just
say yes he's so desperate he is so
desperate ah
he's desperate you got a yes and some
rules of improv yeah yeah man I'll hang
with your buddy he seems like a good guy
I didn't say hang said go on Addie with
that Andrew I'm trying to make your
shout out worth it thank you thank you
buddy no I'm Wow Julia eath cosby's goes
Marin is great way to go now he has
unpledged from the patreon page all
right for you Greg in four and four
your buddy I will I will definitely good
date with is it in DC do I have to go to
DC now I'm sorry Andrew this video is
done we tried